Київський національний університет імені
Тараса Шевченка доктор біологічних наук
професор ракто наукової роботи Маі
Віктор
семевич шановна Михайлівна шановні друзі
Дозвольте я буду тут
Ні тут сподіваюсь що те що я кажу чутно
і нормально да
київськи національни університет ну
традиційно Наш університет є одним із
найбільших університетів є класичним
університетом де практично в нас Не
тільки природничі науки але домінуєть
гуманітарна сфера
ее подалі які це проблеми викликає в
плані науки і науково досліджень і
розвитку наукових досліджень трошки
пізніше але в цілому хочу сказати що Ми
тримаємо наші позиції Ну все ж таки
перши кусії і отримали таіж самісліжня
нагороди перший
S в зв'язку з тим
що маємо хороші давні традиції перше там
по іншим
показникам тримаємо цю Ланку але з
одного боку ми в приємністю констатуємо
що деякі університети насдоганяють Це
добре але це але це означає що ми маємо
працювати краще наступний слайд будь
ласка значить який наш колектив якщо
подивитись
а на наш колектив то він складається
ясноріч освітян і науковців я основну
увагу буду говорити про наш науковий
колектив це штатні співробітники які
працюють саме тільки на виконанні
навгогор тому що я розумію що викладачі
вносять загальний внесок в наукові
дослідження Але разом науководослідна
частина і викладачів дають потужни наці
Якщо говорити про штатних наукових
працівників ми бачимо що у нас є такий
стабільний тренд до зменшення кількості
людей які працюють в науці Ну я думаю що
тут Всі розуміють що це пов'язано з
реальним зменшенням фінансування
потихеньку не дивлячись що сума горівня
простут але реально розуміємо що трошки
з
зменше це стосується в першу чергу
кандидатів наук Якщо говорити про
докторів наук то Ми тримаємо цю нку і
практично зз року в рік У нас приблизно
Та ж сама чна основа зміни стосуються
цих
кандидатких наступний слайд будь ласка
Якщо говорити про підготовку
висококваліфікованих кадрих то ясна річ
що ну є також однії спудниці спудниц
висококваліфікованих наукових
співробітників дані які показані що у
нас
працює 47 вчених спеціалізованих рад
кількість наукових спеціальностей по
якім відбувається захи це
120 кількість дисертацій які захищено
працівниками тільки працівниками
університету Це 428 з них докторській 57
і
кандацьки в нас велика кількість
аспірантів понад 1ся аспірантів Кожен
рік але зараз є така не дуже приємна
тенденція про яку трошки пізніше скажу
наступний слайд будь ласка Якщо говорити
про те як ми готуємо аспірантів то у нас
в останні роки є конкурс до вступу в
аспіранту цей слайд показую
ще можна назада Але тим не менш У нас є
загрозлива тенденція ця тенденція
полягає в то в тому що готуючи наших
аспірантів відправляючи їх за по грантам
там за кордон Вони повертаються і потім
пишуть заяву прошимо просимо відрахувати
в зв'язку з працевлаштуванням або
навчанням за Дона переважна більшість і
як яскравий приклад це О такий меседж
теж для всіх Да я знаю як в інших
університетах у нас такий тренд є і він
Кожен рік посилюється Наприклад ми в
цьому році не в цьому році Ну В тому
році в 16-му році набрали 246 аспіра на
грудень На кінець грудня я підписав
понад 180 заяв переважна більшість яких
полягає в тому що студенти ось аспіранти
під'їжджають до кото зновтаки ж
починають Гран
по програмам обміну а закінчиться тим що
ми втрачаємо І от меседж наш такий що
такі от гаранти Це добре але коли
починаєш читати нашгові угоди там
написано що знотою уснення оподаткування
ниних зборі всь інше інше Я розумію що
захід вкладає гроші свої гроші для того
щоб отримати висококласних спеціалістів
вони якби ми вважаємо працюють на нас
тобку на університет Але реально
практично напри кінці вигода залишається
там тому коли кажуть шановні беріть
гранти і працюйте за грантами да дійсно
це добре але ми маємо створити такий
таку атмосферику да наукових досліджень
щоб наші студенти наши акрати наш
мапонці повертали працювали
це
загальна статистика взагалі по роботі
наших спецрат у нас зафіщається
достатньо багато кандидатських
дисертацій і з інших університетів Т
статистика показано практично із року в
рік ми працюємо стабільно тут ніяких
проблем
нема далі
фінансування значить ну в цілому ми в
16-му році виконали 195 науководослідних
робіт різного характеру з бюджету
бюджетно 61 тема п'ять завершених по них
більш детально розкажу 50 одна прихідна
тема нема часу про це говорити в
майбутніо звіти це вам покажуть але У
нас є договірна тематика і в нас є так
звані платні послуги за допомогою яких
ми заробляємо собіще додатково гроші
наступний слайд будь ласка і тут
показано приблизно фінансування розклад
фінансування ну ясноріч найбільша сума
заходить від держави цеє загальний
державний загальний фонд ми заробили по
спецфонду 21 трошки більше 21 мльона це
гроші які безпосередньо зайшли у нас в
університет міжнародні гранти ми
порахували це називаємо непрями
насходження які як по обміну грошей не
заходять в університет або не заходять
взагалі в Україну але за
такими наші науковці можуть
поїхати тут показана динаміка
динаміка надходжень по різним напрямам
ее значить по руках видна тенденція в
цьому році в 16-му році ми приклали
багато зусиль щоб наше фінансування
особливо по сцфонду послугам зросло і ми
вважаємо що це один із способів і в
майбутньому бачимо певні перспективи
подальшого розвитку коли ми надаємо
послуги вже безпосередньо бізнесу ми
виходимо в практич інноваційну сферу і
ми вже бачимо як як я кажу ляно для
діяльності наступний
слайд Ну що стосується результатів
роботи е в зв'язку з тим що ми класичний
університет у нас домінує фундаментальна
наука
м продуктом нашої діяльності є наших
публікацій публікації стично журналах
Якщо говорити про кількість публікацій
то по рукам вони показані У нас вони
збільшуються зменшуються але в цілому
приблизно так в середньому сть-7і навіть
до 8 000 публікацій на рік ми маємо це
той продукт який ми видаємо Але якщо
говорити про публікацію В
високорейтингових журналах то ситуація
трошки менша інша і вона пов'язана з тим
що і частина публікацій входить в нас в
нашу базу даних купус Але не дивлячись
на тлькі більш низкі показники по цим
базам даних по нарони публікації ми все
одно при що в Україні займаємо першу
позицію традиційно гуманітарна сфера у
нас найбільш продуктивна але вони всі
друкують В журналах які ну мають такі
українські всеукраїнські масштаби це
окрема проблема
ее нам потрібно в Україні і ми над цим
теж працюємо щоб і гуманітарні журнали
виходили на міжнародний
якщо говорити внесок наших різних
підрозділів то якщо взяти по підвести
статистику то приблизно три підрозділи
це фізики хіміки біологи дові основний
внесок в
продукцію в наукову продукцію всі інше
або уманітарні факультети майже майже
майже Ну це якщо рахувати х повазі скос
тобто наша гуманітарія практично свіх не
бачить і над цим треба працювати І це не
тільки наша проблема Я думаю що проблема
всіх
іце Значить ми проводимо аналіз яких
журналах наші науковці пра рукується
тобто перелік в тому числі укранський
журнал фізики є це дуже приємно що він є
міжнародних базах даних українськи
хімічні журнали Я ряд інших е цю
статистику ми ведемо зараз Практично
кожен місяць і дивимось динаміку значить
деякі журнали Наші вже є в скокусі це
теорія магрності математична статистика
цей журнал перекладається математич теі
ст Сполучених Штатів нуми зараз пере
заключаємо договір на основі того щоб ми
університет навіть міг отримавати
рояalті від діяльності цієї так е і ці
кошти знов таки ж використовувати для
розвитку саме от нашої журнальної бази
іде робота над
гуманітарним вісником Київського
національного університету економіка
Значить ми зробили декілька важливих
кроків для того щоб цей журнал війшов
теж базу даних с деякі журнали наші є We
Sci вісни
кінологіологія і астрономічна нажурна і
ми працюємо над іншими жлами так щоб
вони виходили в першу чергу базу даних
яка не є тако провідної але ціє єї
основи яка дозволить нам висти вже
журналу ско
са що стосується міжнародної діяльності
вона у нас дуже широка можна багато чого
говорити от Якщо говорити про горизонт
20 2020 то ці гроші які зайшли в Україну
Вони
приблизно 900 000 євро це проекти які
профінансовані у нас в університеті або
за участю наших учасників якщо говорити
в цілому то згідно бази
даних gfc J cн це в рамках горизонт 2020
та цифра стоїть дуже велика яка нас
Чесно кажучи Навіть трошки схвилювала
Там стоїть 1 600 євро але як виявляється
переважна більшість оцих грошей тобто
понад мільйони вони пішли якраз на
підтримку
облогмінів Ну за рахунок яких я от вже
сказав у нас виникають проблеми із
аспірацію значить деякі проекти мо
можемоза трошки деякі проекти які
фінансуються у нас безпосередньо
фінансується через інноваційні структури
От наприклад компанії Намін разом з
нашими фахівцями виконують Спільний
проект наша розробка е практично їхнє
впровадження вже в е конкретну практику
і таким чином у нас е Ця компанія одна
із є провідних компаній взагалі в Європі
І це дуже ємной за рахунок якраз того що
наша ідея наш потенціал в тому числі
науковий дозволяє зувати о такі
про кожен проект можна говорити окремо
Часу нема тому можна
звернутися хвилини хвилини да далі
затимо значить зробили спеціальні
сторінки в сайті на нашому сайті щоб
люди могли знаходити за кордоном наших
науковців працювати безпосередньо в
досторонньому форматі далі будь ласка
далі давайте Ідемо трансфер технології
наці ми працюємо далі наступний слайд
провели далі провели роботу щодо участі
наших підрозділів в системі НР Працюємо
з підприємством корбон прому
підприємством кван завод Маяк знов таки
ж у нас є розробки брольових пакетів
воми шли випробування наперегодні в нас
є акти шесто рівень захисту для
бронебілетів використовувати не можна
тому що від удару немає але для
протехніки це дуже корисна річ у нас є
замовлення на 300 900 таких пластин для
випробування на техніку у нас головна
проблема де їх Де їх заробити Тому що
наші можливості ми кількості не
дозволяємо не дозволяє наше можливо це
зробити тому ми ведемо кошк наступний
слайд будь ласка Працюємо з закордонними
партнерами які наш є гічно
далі далі Давайте до результатів
перейдемо
далі далі найважливіший результат у нас
в цьому році закінчується п'ять тем
значить дуже коротенько тема яка предста
представляє школаколаївна академії
Миколаївна вона присвячена
фундаментальній проблемі що таке рідина
які властивості цієї рідини якщо ми
використовуємо нарост структуровані
матеріали яким чином там відбуваються
електронетичні процеси і так далі І так
далі
е-е надрукована певна кількість
монографій тут всі дані показані скільки
монографії скільки статей і ця тема
вважається одною з Тако наших потужних
тем була успішно виконана і ми її стуємо
в цьому
році друга тема - це тема нашого
географічного факультету тема та
прикладний характер це зіз технологій
які дозволяють електронні атласи і так
далі значить на виході на виході є
електронна версія АСУ кієва Значить вона
є доступно зараз в мережі і друге У нас
є договір з Київською міською
адміністрацією Ми хочемо ркувати
кольоровий хороший АС Києва на основі
оцих от всіх технологій який буде такою
свого роду виізитівкою міста Києва
наступни слайд соціогуманітарний напрям
соціальний та психологіч педагогічні
аспекти розвитку цілосно особистостей
значить це ее от
У нас є дійсно великі відносно такі
великі по кількості гуманітарних локщо
за фінансування чце одна із те
тут
дичні аспекти розвитку особистості в
певних наших умовах нашої дісності і так
далі є підручники монографії і
публікація наступний слайд ще одна тема
яка була закінчена теж Вона присвячена
творчості Шевченко наш
Шевченко ми вважаємо що дійсно ми
повинні продовжути такі дослідження і от
якраз творчість Шевченка в вимірах
європейського роматизму підготовлена
монографія і я розумію що
ми класичний університет тому і технічні
розробки і гуманітарні розробки є такими
же важливими для виховання нашої молоді
і практично для формування ментальності
нашого народу ми вважаємо що це дуже
важливо
іологи наші вони виконували роботу яка
присвячена аналізу
геоморфології різних
регіонів якщо дуже коротко То як правило
це питання присвячено тому якщо є газ чи
нафта то яким чином вони там лежать і як
дуже добре їх достати з цих всіх
міс якщо дуже коротко є певні
результати наступний слайд це вигоровна
тематика по договорах з з міністерством
і з іншими компаніями хороше досягнення
фотоелектрична електростанція маленька
зроблена конкретний зразок який фактично
можна
нувати
і далі
це стосується розробки фафармої параціі
в інституті багамольця Були знайдені
такі дуже дивні рецептори які реагують
на кислотуються відкриття го масштабу
але наші хіміки разом з біологами і
іншими фахівцями розробляють конкретні
конкретні речовини які блокують яі
рецептори Таким чином знімають больові
відчуття Тобто це такі буде наступний
слайд а
тема оптичні явища в металоічних
діалектиках Щека значить теж є
а е хороше досягнення не буду зупинятись
в деталях але ще один проект це на
настрові толкі нарозабі пробідників для
ефективного використання сонічної
енергії хочу сказати що всі
ідея впроваджується конкретний продукт
сонячних маленьких яких станці в нас є
певні завдання які ми ми маємо
безпосередньо вирішити в університеті от
є певні пропозиції які пов'язані з тим
що бажано Коли проводиться оцінка оцінка
проектів які заходять на конкурс щоб
можливо
якісь там це інноваційна спрямованість і
знов таки ж наскільки поперед результати
були впроваджені безпосередньо в
практику бізнес от Ну і останній слайд
значить додаткову інформацію ви можете
побачити про наштовки на сайті
університету я вам ще раз дякую за дякую
дякую дуже вікто се чи є запитання до
Віктора
сименовича Ну мене тільки одне хотілося
б знати Ви сказали Віктор сименовичу ви
збираєтесь пророл отримувати збираємо
яким чином неприбуткова організацію Ми
заму ро ми їх я так і це озвучив ми це
це питання ми вивчаємо справа в тім що
деякі інститути в Академії Наук давно
працюють отримують наук академія наук
самоврядна організації в якій є багато
Ого що не дозволено нашим ми це вивчаємо
Якщо у нас будуть як там позитивний
результат Ми всім із всіма подівимося Я
розумію що лці це може отри ти тільки
організація яка є яка отримує
прибут вот як ми це оформили Я поки що
не
знаю цікаво з вами попрацювати в плані
пошуку тому що це питання дуже нагально
ть навчальних закладів воно стримує
напрацювання Да і накопичення
накопичення коштів для розвитку як
тільки у нас буде якийсь результат ми
обов'язково вам доповімо ві чи в цьому
контексті ви розглядали можливості
вашого наукового парку
значить На жаль часу було дуже мало
науковий парк у нас працює як наша така
організація вона є
корпорація яку утворили декілька установ
ми голо і науковий парк Він у нас працює
як інноваційна структура Ну не у нас
вона незалежна дична ока а особа Але
разм я вважаю дуже успішні речі не було
часу показати це наше спільні
засідання з представниками бізнесу наше
засідання Ради ректорів підприємств
міста Києва це інноваційний фестиваль
інновацій Київського національного
університету
ми були переможці за залучений за
допомогою парку бізнес який практично
оцінював нашу розробки не науковці а
саме бізнес і саме це науковий парк нам
допоміг це все організувати і далі ми
плануємо в цьому році вже можливо під
даху Міністерства освіти Ми проведемо
всеукраїнський фестиваль Можливо на
нашому
майданчику за тією схемою яку ми
наприклад пропонуємо Я сподіваюсь що цей
проект У нас теж получиться Дякую дуже і
науковий парк там буде одним
організатора в першу чергу для
заробляння
грошеймови фестивалі ні але
фестивалікрема як окрема розмова які
проблеми у наших парків є Я думаю що
варто Міністерство взагалі зробити
окреме засідання саме по цих проблеми що